[Music]
my name is Johanna Stowe and this is my
life in pictures I grew up in Malaysia
in a small town called Tran Ghana which
is located in Southeast Asia
and most well known for its beautiful
beaches and Islands my parents met got
married and they had my brother two
years later they brought me into this
world on the 22nd of September when my
parents had me everyone around them
thought they had given birth to another
baby boy because I had very little hair
up to five years oh I guess that's the
reason for my mom to dress and doll me
up just so I would look like a little
girl my dad owns a small local furniture
shop and my mom was a primary school
teacher my dad is a pet lover and
growing up we had many dogs in our home
there was once where we had up to ten
dogs but of course we had to give them
away I would turn together has always
been with nature we would swim in the
river or Beach go camping together and
basically just to experience the
traditional life of my town growing up
my parents had very little but they have
always worked very hard to give us the
best of what they can my mom would get
us involved with dancing and acting
performances in our local church and she
would save art and send us for piano
lessons it has always been a dream to
play the piano but she just did not have
the privilege to as a child so she
wanted to provide us with as many
different opportunities as possible so
as a team I played the keyboards guitar
and bass in my church I was a write
tomboy then and I still am in a way my
mom has always dreamt of graduating with
a degree but with the lack of funding
she couldn't afford to further her
studies that however never stopped her
with the monthly savings that she made
as a teacher and with my father's
support she pursued law through distant
learning and eventually graduated it was
a challenging path for our
especially being Asian most Asians
mentality is that once you're married as
a woman it is your duty to care for your
family and in a way to leave all your
dreams behind so she didn't receive much
support from her friends and external
family members when she finally
graduated we went to London together for
her graduation and to visit other parts
of Europe that was my family's first
vacation together abroad my parents only
had enough savings to pay for the air
tickets accommodation and food so all
the winter clothings were borrowed from
other family members notice the
oversized jackets my brother and I had
on one thing my mom has taught me is
never be afraid to dream and it's never
too late to pursue your dreams when
opportunities do not come your way make
it own path and create your own
opportunities I am extremely proud of
her
following in my parents footsteps I have
always been adventurous and sick to
learn and experience as much as I can in
life so at the age of 15 I went to Japan
under a student exchange program where I
experienced the Japanese culture for
three weeks with two lovely host
families I went to the school met the
town's mayor wore a kimono and even gave
my first Japanese speech since then I
aim to visit one new country every year
and to keep discovering the beautiful
world around me one of the unforgettable
adventures was my first bungee jump in
New Zealand I chickened out and the
instructor had to push me off the cliff
it was extremely terrifying for me would
I do it again probably in 10 years time
or never in high school I had three best
girlfriends we would pretty much do
everything together I was enrolled in
the science classes because in Malaysia
studying science is deemed to have a
more promising future I was never really
interested in the subjects and so my
only drive to go to school was because
of my involvement in my school drama
team that's the only thing I really look
forward to every day so when I graduated
from high school I knew I wanted to
to performing arts the people around me
hugely discouraged me and consider it to
be a waste of my career because I
graduated with pretty good results you
were taught to study hard to be a doctor
lawyer accountant engineer basically the
typical jobs that most Asians called
secure and highly respected I went
against the norm and enrolled to pursue
theater and film instead I was blessed
to have the full support from both my
parents to pursue what I wanted because
most of my friends had to study what
their parents thought was best for them
and not what they truly wanted so at the
age of 17 I left my town to go to
college in the capital of Malaysia Kuala
Lumpur it's always a dream for someone
who is from a small child to go to a big
city I met a new group of friends
started discovering myself even more and
did many different things I did modeling
film acting theater acting but one thing
that would change my life forever was
when I started going to the gym because
I was called pleasantly plump and
eventually I enrolled to be certified as
a personal trainer whilst still in
college I then started training with
Fitness fest Malaysia and eventually
resigned when I arrived to further my
degree in the UK this was another big
step in my life to leave everyone I knew
behind to go to an unknown place I had
no idea what my future lies for me but I
father need to expand to learn and to
experience more so as I was searching
and praying something inside me tell me
that I should go to the UK to complete
my degree and start there I have always
listened to my gut feelings and have
faith that everything would work out for
the best my parents did not have the
full fund to support my studies to the
UK it was expensive as our Malaysian
currency is very low one pound equals
five ringgit so that's five times at the
amount of everything so we applied for a
local scholarship having faith that I
would be accepted if it's meant for me
to go to the UK which I did yes
and with some money saved up from my
personal training I flew there on
September 2010
in the UK I worked part-time as a
fitness instructor to partially support
myself and eventually graduated after
graduation the dream was to go to London
and get a job in TV production which I
did I applied for a job as a TV producer
and worked in London for nine months but
it wasn't as rewarding because I felt
the need to connect with people which is
why I love fitness training I can't
really remember how I stumble upon the
idea of filming YouTube videos but I
remember telling my mom that I would
like a video camera for my birthday and
that I would start filming my workout
videos and posted them online
my mum had no idea how it would work
neither did I all I knew was that I had
to connect with all of you around the
world and to share my passion for
healthy living I knew how to film and
edit so why not take this risk I thought
to myself what do I have to lose do I
want to stay stuck in a job and
environment I don't enjoy just to
survive or would I take this risk and go
on this adventure and see where it will
lead me so I told my mom to give me one
year to make this work and as always my
parents have been very supportive in my
decisions
I created my job took the courage to
film edited posted and shared my very
first workout video on the 28th of
February I remember being really nervous
and I still AM to see the response that
I'll get obviously no one knew about me
or my videos but I just kept going
having faith that eventually I'll be
able to share my personal fitness and
life journey with all of you I strive to
improve myself learn from the feedback I
received and most importantly to connect
with all of you personally I would spend
hours sometimes even up to eight hours
just sitting in front of my laptop reply
to all your comments as much as I am
sharing my life fitness journey and
knowledge with you I am learning and
discovering even more about myself
through all your comments questions
encouragement and love my life is always
changing and evolving so it
is very important for us to count our
blessings every day one thing I know is
that I love making videos to inspire and
connect with all of you this is just the
beginning of my new chapter and this is
something I'll keep doing I am blessed
with a family that supports my dreams
and decisions even when I do not know
what I'm doing or when others discourage
me my parents have always taught me to
pray trust in your instincts and have
faith that life will guide you to your
purpose and now I have you guys no
matter where you're at in your life
right now
never stop learning discovering and most
importantly to take charge of your
emotions and life you are the creator of
your own destiny
I love you guys
[Music]
you